The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
MICHAEL SHORT: Hey guys, hope
you enjoyed the brief break
from the heavy technical stuff.
Because we're going to
get right back into it
and develop the neutron
transport equation today,
the one that you
see on everybody's
t-shirts here in the department.
So I think multiple
years folks have
used this equation on the
back of t-shirts just be like,
we're awesome.
And we do difficult math.
Well, this is what you're
going to start to do it.
In fact, it's big
enough and hard enough
that we're going to spend
all day today developing it,
like actually writing out
the terms of the equation
and understanding what
it actually means.
Before, on Thursday
and Friday, we're
going to reduce it down to
a much simpler equation,
something that you can
actually solve and do
some simple reactor
calculations with.
We started off the whole idea of
the neutron transport equation
as a way to track some
population of neutrons.
Let's see, I'm going to have
our variable list up here.
What I'll probably do is
on Thursday and Friday
I'll just have it
back up on the screens
so that we don't have
to write it twice.
But there's going to be a lot
of variables in this equation.
I'm going to do my
best, again, to make
the difference between V and nu
very obvious, and anything else
like that.
But the goal is to track
some population of neutrons,
at some position,
at some energy,
traveling in some direction
omega, as a function of time.
And the 3D representation of
what we're looking at here
is let's say we had some
small volume element, which
we'll call that our dV.
That's got normal vectors
sticking out of it.
We'll call those n-hats
in all directions.
And inside there, let's say
if this is our energy scale,
we're tracking the
population of neutrons
that occupies some
small energy group dE,
and is also traveling
in some small direction
that we designate as d-omega.
So that's the goal of
this whole equation
is to track the number of
neutrons at any given position.
So let's call this
distance, or the vector r.
In this little volume, traveling
in some direction omega,
with some infinitesimally
small energy group d.
That's going to be the
goal of the whole thing.
And what we'll do
is write this to say
the change in the population of
neutrons at a given distance,
energy, angle, and
time, over time
is just going to be a sum
of gain and loss terms.
And what I think we'll
take all day today to do
is to figure out what are
the actual physical things
that neutrons can do in
and out of this volume,
and how do we turn those
into math, something
that we can abstract and solve?
There's a couple
other terms that we're
going to put up here.
We'll say that the flux of
neutrons, which is usually
the variable that
we actually track,
is just the velocity times
the neutron population.
And also let's define some
angularly independent terms.
Because in the end
we've been talking
about what's the
probability of some neutron
or particle interacting
with some electron going out
at some angle.
But as we're interested in
how many neutrons are there
in the reactor, we usually
don't care in which direction
they're traveling.
So the first simplification
that we will do
is get rid of any sort
of angular dependence,
getting rid of two of
the seven variables
that we're dealing with here.
So all these
variables right here
will be dependent on angle.
And all these
variables right here
will be angularly independent.
So there'll be some
corresponding capital
N, or number of neutrons as
a function of r, E, and t.
We'll call this Flux.
We'll call this Number.
There's going to be a
number of cross sections
that we need to worry about.
So we'll refer to little
sigma as a function of energy,
as our micro-cross-section,
and big sigma of E
as a macroscopic cross-section.
Then you want to remember the
relation between these two.
AUDIENCE: Solid angle?
MICHAEL SHORT: The
solid angle, not quite.
That's, let's see.
There's a difference
between-- and so
what these physically
mean is little sigma
means the probability of
interaction with one particle.
And this is just the
total probability
of interaction with all the
particles that may be there.
So yeah, Chris?
AUDIENCE: Number density?
MICHAEL SHORT: There's
number density.
Already we have another
variable conflict.
How do we want to resolve this?
Let's see.
We'll have to change
the symbol somehow.
Let's make it cursive.
Don't know what else to do.
I don't want to give it
a number other than n
since we're talking
about neutrons,
or that right here it's
going to be number density.
And in the end, we're worried
about some sort of reaction
rate, which is always
going to equal some flux,
or let's just stick with some
angularly dependent flux,
that r, E omega t,
times some cross-section
as a function of energy.
And it's these
reaction rates that
are the rates of gains
and losses of neutrons
out of this volume, out
of this little angle,
out of this energy group,
and out of that space,
or into that volume
energy group and space.
So let's see, other terms
that we'll want to define
include nu, like last time.
We'll call this
neutron multiplication.
In other words,
this is the number
of neutrons made on average
during each fission event.
And we give it energy
dependence because as we
saw on the Janis libraries
on Friday, I think it was.
What's today, Tuesday?
I don't even know anymore.
I think as we saw on Friday,
that depends on energy
for the higher energy levels.
And there's also
going to be some Kai
spectrum, or some
neutron birth spectrum,
which tells you the average
energy at which neutrons
are born from fission.
So regardless of what energy
goes in to cause the fission,
there's some
probability distribution
of a neutron being born
at a certain energy.
And it looks something like
this, where that's about 1 MeV.
That's about 10 MeV.
And that average right
there is around 2 MeV.
And so it's important
to note that neutrons
are born at different energies.
Because we want to track
every single possible dE
throughout this
control volume, which
we'll also call a reactor.
Let's see, what other
terms will we need to know?
The different types
of cross sections,
or the different
interactions that neutrons
can have with matter.
What are some of the ones
that we had talked about?
What can neutrons do
when they run into stuff?
AUDIENCE: Scatter.
MICHAEL SHORT: They can scatter.
So there's going to be some
scattering cross-section.
And when they scatter,
the important part
here is they're going
to change in energy.
What else can they do?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Absorbed.
MICHAEL SHORT: They
can be absorbed.
So we'll have some
sigma absorption.
What are some of the various
things that can happen
when a neutron is absorbed?
AUDIENCE: Fission.
MICHAEL SHORT: Yeah, so
one of them is fission.
What are some of the other ones?
AUDIENCE: Capture.
MICHAEL SHORT: Yep, capture.
What were some of the
ones that we talked about
during the Chadwick paper?
AUDIENCE: Neutron [INAUDIBLE].
MICHAEL SHORT: Yep,
so there can be some--
we'll call it n,in, which means
one neutron goes in, i neutrons
come out, so 1 to
i neutrons, sure.
Anything else?
Encompassed in absorption?
Well when we refer to scatter
here, what type of scattering
are we talking about?
AUDIENCE: Compton's scatter?
MICHAEL SHORT:
Compton's for photons.
It's OK.
Was it elastic or
inelastic scattering?
AUDIENCE: Elastic.
MICHAEL SHORT:
Elastic scattering.
So another thing you could call
an absorption event, depending
on what bin you put things
in, is inelastic scattering,
which is that kind of--
we call it scattering
because one neutron goes in,
one neutron comes out.
But in reality, you have
a compound nucleus forming
and a neutron emitted from
a different energy level.
So it doesn't follow the
simple ballistic laws of,
and kinematic laws of
inelastic scattering.
What else can neutrons do?
Now we're getting into
the real esoteric stuff.
But I want to see if
you guys have any idea.
Did you know that
neutrons can decay?
A low neutron is actually
not a stable particle.
If you look up on the
Kyrie table of nuclides,
it's got a half
life of 12 minutes.
So if you happen
to be able to have
neutrons in a bottle or
something, which we actually
can do.
There's centers for
ultra-cold neutrons and atoms.
There's one at North Carolina
State where they actually cool
down neutrons to cryogenic
temperatures to the point where
they can actually confine them.
They only live on
average 12 minutes.
And then there would
also be what we call
a neutron-neutron interactions.
There is a finite,
non-zero but very small
probability that neutrons
can hit other neutrons.
But the mean-free path for
these is on the order of 10
to the 8th centimeters.
So this is not something
we have to consider.
But it's interesting to
know that yes, neutrons
can run into other neutrons.
And these sorts of things
have been measured.
We won't have to
worry about this.
We won't have to worry
about neutron decay.
But it's interesting to note
that a low neutron is not
a stable particle.
It will spontaneously
undergo beta decay,
into a proton and an electron.
Pretty neat, huh?
Anyway, if we sum up all
these possible interactions,
we have one other
cross-section, which
we're going to call the total
cross-section, the probability
of absolutely any
interaction occurring at all.
Because any sort of
interaction of that neutron
is going to cause removal from
this group of energy position,
angle, location, whatever.
Whether it's absorption, or
fission, or elastic scattering,
or inelastic scattering,
any sort of event--
except for forward scattering,
which means nothing happens--
is going to result in this
neutron either leaving
the volume.
So it might scatter out
of our little volume.
Or it might change direction,
scatter out of our d-omega.
Or it will lose
some energy, or gain
some energy, in some cases,
leaving our little dE, which
is what we're trying to track.
Because we're actually
tracking what's
the population of neutrons
in this little dE,
in this direction, in this
position, at this time.
And supposedly if we
know this term fully,
we can solve for
all the neutrons
everywhere, anywhere in the
reactor with full information.
So what we'll spend
the rest of today doing
is figuring out what are all the
possible gain and loss terms.
So let's start just putting them
out physically, or in words.
And then we'll put them to math.
So what are some of the
ways in which neutrons
can enter our little group
of volume, angle, and energy?
How are neutrons created?
Yeah, Luke?
AUDIENCE: From fission,
or a neutron emission.
MICHAEL SHORT: From fission,
yeah, so that's one big source.
So we'll call this a gains.
This is a losses.
And you said a neutron source.
Can you be more specific?
AUDIENCE: A neutron
emission, like [INAUDIBLE]..
MICHAEL SHORT: OK, so we'll
say n,in reactions, right?
OK, cool.
How else can we gain neutrons?
AUDIENCE: Fusion?
MICHAEL SHORT: Fusion?
OK.
That is true.
Although fusion
reactors don't really
operate on the principle of
neutron criticality, or neutron
balance.
So this discussion
for now is going
to be limited to
fission reactors.
But yeah, good point.
Fusion does make neutrons.
What else?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: They could enter from
one of the adjacent volume?
MICHAEL SHORT: Yeah, they
could come from somewhere else,
right?
Let's just call that
an external source.
In the books and
in your reading,
you'll just see them
treat this external source
as some variable s
of r, E, omega, t.
So you'll just see this
treated as s, a source,
with no further explanation.
It's like, oh, math
says that there
could be external sources.
But I want to tell you
where they really come from.
Most reactors
nowadays don't just
start up when you throw a
bunch of uranium into a pool
and pull out the control rods.
You actually have to stick in--
if this is your little
reactor right here--
you actually have to stick in
a little piece of californium--
I think the isotope is 252--
as what we call a
kickstarter source.
So californium is made mostly
in the HFIR, or the High Flux
Isotope Reactor, at the Oakridge
National Lab in Tennessee,
where they have a really,
really high power reactor.
It's 85 megawatts.
It's about that big
around and this tall.
It's really, really small.
For reference, that's about
the size of the MIT reactor,
except our reactor's
6 megawatts.
Theirs is 85 megawatts.
And it's designed to be
an incredibly high flux,
to go by neutron capture, and
neutron capture reactions,
to build up californium
252, which is spontaneously
giving off neutrons like crazy.
And this right here, that's
your external source.
And this helps get
reactors going.
Because you can
either very slowly
wait for the fission
reaction to build up
in a controlled manner.
Or you can give it a kick in
the pants and get it going.
This HFIR reactor
is pretty cool.
Like I said, it's 85 megawatts.
And it's about as
dense as it can get.
The fuel is actually made by
explosively bonding sheets
of uranium in a certain sort of
semi-cylindrical configuration.
And it produces so much
decay heat in so little space
that if it were to lose
cooling, the reactor
would melt in 8 seconds.
You usually have
days or so before
that happens in a
conventional reactor
because the power density
just isn't that high.
So you can actually
see down to the tank
that contains HFIR if you go
for a tour at Oakridge National
Lab.
And it's way down below this
gigantic like, not quite
Olympic, but getting
there sized pool of water,
just to make sure
that there is adequate
cooling for this thing.
It's intense.
But that's just a notice
that these external sources,
these are real things that
we use in power reactors
to get them going.
What are some other ways
that one could make neutrons,
or that neutrons could
enter into our energy group?
And the silence is expected
because this is usually
the hardest part of
developing this equation.
And I want to introduce it.
Yeah, Luke?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
scattering, too.
MICHAEL SHORT:
That's exactly it.
They can scatter in.
So when we develop this
neutron transport equation,
we're not just
tracking the neutrons
in this little energy group dE,
direction, d-omega, and volume
dV.
You actually have to know what's
the population of neutrons
in every single group.
Because you might have a neutron
at a higher energy level that
undergoes scattering from
some different energy,
E-prime into our energy group.
So continuing with our
gigantic list of variables,
we're going to call E
is, we'll say r energy.
And this vector omega
is our direction,
the one that we're tracking.
And E-prime is going to
be some other energy.
And omega-vector-prime is
going to be some coming
from some other direction.
And like Luke said,
this is what we
would refer to as in-scattering,
which means some neutron comes,
that was going in a
different direction, that
did have a different
energy, and has now
entered into the single
group that we're tracking.
Eventually we're going to
integrate over all energies
to track all energy groups.
So that's where we're going.
And there's one more term that
I want to introduce right now.
It's what's called
the scattering kernel.
Don't ask me why
it's called kernel.
But this is just the terminology
I want you guys to get used to.
And there's going to be some
sort of probability function
where a neutron starts off at
a different energy, E-prime,
and in a different
direction, omega-prime.
And it enters into our group
energy E and direction omega.
Right now we'll leave it as
a highly general function.
What we're going to find
later is there's just
some sort of simple line to it.
If you guys remember, if
some neutron starts off,
let's see, probability of
entering into some energy
group.
If you notice, if you
remember from last time,
the neutron, when it undergoes
any sort of scattering
reaction, can end
up with any energy
between its original energy
for the case of theta equals 0,
and this parameter, alpha
energy, for the case theta
equals pi, where
alpha is A minus 1,
over A plus 1 squared,
where A is the atomic mass.
You guys remember this
from back in the Q equation
days, when we were
finding out what's
the probability that a neutron
coming in with energy E
ends up at any energy E-prime?
Actually I'll just write this
as the scattering kernel.
What it ends up looking
like, in most cases,
is just a flat line.
There's an equal probability of
the neutron ending up anywhere
between energy E and
anywhere between energy
alpha-E. It's actually a
pretty simple function.
It's just a constant value
here and 0 everywhere else.
What that means is
that if, let's say,
a neutron hits a uranium
atom, there is no way in hell
that it can transfer
all of its energy
to a uranium atom because
of conservation of energy
and momentum, like we've
been harping on for kind
of this whole class.
What's the only time that
this alpha-E could actually
extend all the way to 0?
What case would that be?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: You're
hitting another neutron.
MICHAEL SHORT: You're hitting
another neutron, which,
as we said, is a
very rare event.
That is true.
Or what else could
you be hitting?
AUDIENCE: A proton?
MICHAEL SHORT: A proton,
hydrogen. That's right.
So it can only be,
let's say you can only
have the probability of
the neutron ending up
with any energy for the case
of hydrogen. Incidentally,
this is why we fill
light water reactors
with hydrogen.
The goal is to get
the neutrons as slow as
possible as quick as possible.
Interesting sentence
to say there, right?
We want the neutrons to be
as low energy as possible
as rapidly as possible.
And the best way to do
that is to fill the reactor
with hydrogen because then any
collision could, in theory, get
the neutron down to zero energy.
Without water, or something
with the same mass as a neutron,
like another neutron,
there is no way
that that neutron can
slow down by very much.
So even though we're
going to keep it
as this generalized function,
note that in reality it's
this pretty simple function.
It changes a little
bit, as there
can be a forward scattering
bias for some neutron reactions.
But we are not going to
deal with that this year.
You will deal with that
next year in 22.05.
So I've been saying a
lot, oh, well, we're
not going to go into this topic
because you're going to see it
in 22.02, which is quantum.
Now I switched
gears to say, we're
not going to go into the
way this function changes
because you'll see it
next year in 22.05,
which is neutron physics.
But for now I want you
to be prepared for 22.05.
So we'll put on in-scattering
as one of our gains.
There's a last one I want
to make you aware of.
We very briefly touched upon it.
But I wouldn't be surprised
if no one remembers because it
was for like 10 seconds.
It's what's called
photo fission.
What this means is you have some
reaction that would, in comes
a gamma, and out goes fission.
This actually does start to
happen around 3 or 4 MeV,
for isotopes like uranium 235.
And in our reactor, whatever
shape we decide it is,
there are tons of gamma rays
flying about in all directions
at very high energy.
Does anyone remember
where they come from?
Anyone remember the
fission timeline
that we drew on Friday?
So what we said
there was right away,
let's say fission happens.
And almost instantly, you
get your fission product one
and fission product two.
And they move around
for a little while.
And then some of them
will emit some neutrons.
And then some of them will
start to emit gamma rays, betas,
and whatever else they're
going to do until they finally
lose all their kinetic energy
and stop in the surrounding
fuel, creating the heat that
actually powers the turbine
and make steam to
make electricity.
And so it's from these
gammas, as well as
any of the gammas from the
decay products of the fission
products that lead to a huge
flux of gamma rays firing out
from all sides in the reactor.
That's one of the main
things that you actually have
to shield in a nuclear reactor.
Since we talked about all
sorts of different shielding,
and all sorts of ways that
you have to shield things,
you know from seeing the MIT
reactor-- which you all did--
that there's like six
feet of lead and concrete
shielding around the reactor.
It's not there to shield
the alphas and the betas,
because those don't really
make it out of the water.
It's not there to shield
the soft X-rays that betas
make from bremsstrahlung.
It's also not there
to shield the neutrons
because the neutrons
don't really get out.
They bounce around, or
get absorbed in the water,
or the fuel, the reflector.
It's there to shield the
high-energy gamma rays.
Because the only
thing that stops
high energy gamma
rays is lots of mass
in between the source and you.
So we know there's tons
of gammas all about.
So let's say there's also going
to be some gamma ray flux.
There'll be some
gamma ray energy.
And there'll be some
cross-section for photo fission
as a function of the incoming
gamma ray energy spectrum.
Now I'm adding terms to the ones
that you'll see in the reading
because drawing them out in math
is actually fairly instructive.
They all follow
the same pattern.
So instead of just
showing you one of each
and saying memorize, we'll
develop a whole lot of these.
And you'll find
out that they all
actually look almost the same.
Can anyone else think of any
possible gains of neutrons?
Where else could they come from?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Neutron birth
spectrum, is that?
MICHAEL SHORT: So the
neutron birth spectrum
is included in fission.
So our nu is in there.
Our chi of E is in there.
And that's a nu of E.
That's all accounted
for in the fission term.
And we'll see how we put
that together to math.
And if no one else has
any ideas, that's good.
Because neither do I.
Now what about the lost terms?
There aren't too many
of these, as long
as you lump them correctly.
So what sort of
ways could neutrons
be lost from our energy group?
Yep?
AUDIENCE: Scatter out.
MICHAEL SHORT: Scatter out, yep.
They can undergo any kind
of scattering reaction.
And they will probably
change direction and energy.
What else?
Well, we've got to list up on
the board right there, right?
Capture, fission,
because in order
to undergo a vision you
actually have to lose a neutron,
and so on, and so on, and so on.
What I want to do to
simplify things is this.
It's a lot simpler just to
track the total cross-section,
the probability
of any interaction
at all whatsoever,
because any interaction
will cause the neutron to
either change energy and angle,
or disappear, even if it
makes some other ones.
So we can simplify this to just
the total cross-section term.
And there's only one
other way that neutrons
can leave our energy
angle and volume group.
What would that be?
So any reaction takes
care of energy and angle.
What about volume?
How do neutrons leave
the control volume?
It's simpler than it may sound.
They just go.
They just move.
The neutrons are
always moving, right?
We'll call that leakage.
Because every neutron's got a
speed, like we showed up here,
where the flux of
neutrons, the number
of neutrons moving through
some surface per second,
is just their velocity times
the number that are there.
For there to be a
neutron flux there
has to be a velocity, which
means the neutrons are moving.
So the neutrons, even without
undergoing any reaction,
could just move out
of our control volume.
And then they're gone.
And that's all there is
for gain and loss terms.
So let's see if we can
do this all on one board.
I want to start putting this
table right here into math
that we'll be able to abstract,
simplify, and then solve,
but not today, not solve today.
So if we want to
track the change
in the number of neutrons
as a function of time,
let's start writing
down the gain terms.
So how do we describe
the number of neutrons
produced from fission?
What sort of terms do
we have to include?
And Jared started kicking us
off, so what would you say?
AUDIENCE: Neutron birth?
MICHAEL SHORT: Yep, so the
neutron birth spectrum,
there's going to be some
probability that a neutron is
born in our energy
group E. Because we're
tracking how many neutrons are
in our little dE energy group.
What else matters
in terms of fission?
AUDIENCE: Number of fissions?
MICHAEL SHORT: Yep,
number of fissions.
So if we want to write
number of fissions,
we have to write that
as a reaction rate.
So let's take those
two terms right there.
So we'll have sigma fission.
In this case, we're going
to write E-prime times flux
of r E-prime, omega-prime, t.
Why did I write E
and omega prime here?
Just from a physical reason.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So you're going to
be coming from another energy
group.
MICHAEL SHORT: Precisely.
That's right.
So the neutrons are going to be
produced from some other energy
group.
For example, the fission
birth spectrum right here
starts out--
where did it go?
I knew I drew it
somewhere-- at one MeV.
But most of the neutrons
that cause fission to happen
are way down below 1 eV.
So it's different
energy neutrons
that cause neutrons to be
born in our energy group.
That's why we're using
E-prime and not E.
It's some other energy group.
And so we also have to account
for all possible other energy
groups.
So if we want to write
this, right, we'll
say this could be as low as
0 eV, to our maximum energy.
And there's going to be some
d-omega-prime, dE-prime, dV.
We'll also have to account
for all possible angles
and integrate over
our entire volume.
It's going to look ugly
quick, but it's all
going to be understandable.
So what this says
is that we have
to account for the
reaction rate of fission
from all other energy
neutrons inside our volume
from other energies
and other angles,
and account for every
other possible energy.
Because they can all
make fission happen.
What else is missing in terms
of describing the number
of neutrons made from fission?
AUDIENCE: Neutron
multiplication.
MICHAEL SHORT: Yep,
there's the number
of neutrons made per fission.
So we have to put in our
neutron multiplication factor.
And in this case, normalize--
I think someone had mentioned
solid angle-- we normalize over
all possible angles with
an over 4 pi in there.
And this right here
is the fission term.
So this tells us the
number of neutrons
gained in terms of
a reaction rate,
times the number of neutrons
for each of those reactions,
times the probability
that there just
happened to be born
in the energy group
that we're tracking.
So is there any term here
that's unclear to folks?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So what's the lower
bound on the first integral?
MICHAEL SHORT: On
the first integral?
That 0 electron volts.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
MICHAEL SHORT:
Because supposedly you
could have a neutron
at 0 eV, which
has a very high cross-section.
So it should probably
induce fission.
In reality, there might be some
actual minimum temperature.
But there is a
non-zero probability
that you could have
a neutron at rest.
It's just not very large.
AUDIENCE: And the top bound?
MICHAEL SHORT: The top
bound as E max, whatever
your maximum neutron energy is.
This is usually around 10 MeV,
for most fission reactors.
That E max is going to be this
point right here, the highest
energy at which neutrons
can be born by any process.
And so this term
right here is going
to serve as a template for all
the other gain and loss terms.
So I think this is the
hardest one that we had
to develop from the beginning.
Now let's develop the
term for, let's just
go with external
sources, pretty easy.
There's going to be some
source making neutrons.
It's something that
you would just impose.
Like say, all right, I have a
californium source giving off
this many neutrons.
Well then you know how many
neutrons it's giving off.
And that one's done.
That's easy.
So we've done fission.
We've done external.
Now that we've done fission
let's tackle photo fission.
So what would be photo fission
cross-section look like?
It's going to look
awfully similar.
So what sort of
things do you need
to know if it's a
fission reaction?
Well, what do we have up here?
Just start reading things off.
I heard a murmur.
What was that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] flux.
MICHAEL SHORT: Yeah,
so you're going
to have to have some flux.
In this case, we want to know
what's the flux of gamma rays
because photo fission
starts off with a gamma,
then ends up with a fission.
And it's also going
to be in our volume.
It's going to matter what the
energy of those gammas is.
They'll all be traveling in
some direction at some time.
What else do we need?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the 4 pi [INAUDIBLE]..
MICHAEL SHORT:
Yeah, if we're going
to be going over all
angles, you need the 4 pi.
What else?
Do we have a reaction rate yet?
AUDIENCE: No.
MICHAEL SHORT: No,
well what's missing?
AUDIENCE: The cross-section.
MICHAEL SHORT: That's right.
We need a cross-section.
And in this case,
instead of just fission,
or neutron fission, we'll
put in the gamma fission
cross-section.
And so now we have a reaction
rate for a single reaction.
We've got to integrate
over all of our gamma ray
energies, over all
angles, over our volume.
What else is missing besides
our d-omega, dE gamma, d-Volume.
It should look awfully similar
because the terms are basically
exactly the same, with just
different cross sections
and energies in there.
So what's missing between the
photo fission and the neutron
fission one?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHAEL SHORT: Sure, there
might be some different birth
spectrum for gammas.
And there might be some
different multiplication
factor for gammas between
neutron fission and photo
fission.
But these terms should
look exactly the same
because in every case you're
looking at some reaction
rate between either the neutrons
and fission or the gamma
and fission.
And you need to know at
what energy they're born,
how many are made,
all the angles,
and integrate overall the
variables that we care about.
And this is part of why I'm
adding these extra terms
because they end up looking
all exactly the same.
It's the integral of a
reaction rate times some stuff.
That's all that every single one
of these terms is going to be.
So we've got photo fission.
Now let's tackle in-scattering.
So how do we
represent scattering?
In the same way that we
represented fission, what do we
start with inside the integral?
AUDIENCE: Reaction rate?
MICHAEL SHORT:
Reaction rate, yes.
So we're going to have some
scattering cross-section.
And if it's in
the scattering, it
means it's coming from a
different energy, hence
the prime.
We'll have our flux.
And here's where we're going to
bring in our scattering kernel.
Because there's some
probability that the neutron
scatters in from
a different group.
And then we'll have our
d-omega, dE-prime, dV.
Is this complete yet?
We've now accounted for
one other energy, E-prime.
Now how do we account for
all possible other energies
scattering into
our energy group?
AUDIENCE: Integrals.
MICHAEL SHORT: Yep,
again, same integrals.
We integrate over all
possible energies,
over all possible angles,
and over our volume.
Hopefully these terms
are looking very similar.
In every case it's a volume,
angle, energy integral
of a reaction rate.
And all that's saying is there's
some rate that these reactions
are occurring, which is either
a gain rate or a loss rate.
We integrate over whatever
volume, energy, and angle
we're tracking.
And that's all there is to it.
So we've got in-scattering.
Now let's tackle
the n,in reactions.
There's only going to be
one little difference.
But I want you guys to
tell me what sort of things
are going to be the same
as all the other terms
that we have here.
So what do we start off
with inside the integral?
AUDIENCE: Reaction rate.
MICHAEL SHORT: A reaction rate.
And how do we write that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MICHAEL SHORT: Yep,
a cross-section,
there's going to be
some cross-section,
for, let's call it n,in reaction
as a function of energy,
times a flux.
There'll be our normal
integrated over all angles,
all energies, and our volume.
So we have a reaction rate.
What do we have to then
integrate that reaction right
over to get all the neutrons in?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
same things.
MICHAEL SHORT: Same things
as everything else, exactly.
Integrate over all
possible energies,
integrate over all
possible angles,
integrate over our volume,
looks quite similar.
The only thing we haven't dealt
with is this i term right here.
Because there can be, there are
actually n,2n reactions, n,3n,
n,4n, and so on.
So there are probabilities
that, let's say
you, in goes 1 neutron,
out comes 3 neutrons.
But no fission
actually happened.
You just blast a
few of them out.
So I think all we'd really have
to do is sum over i equals 1.
Oh, I'm sorry, i equals
2, because a neutron
going in and then the
same neutron going out,
that's just scattering.
And what would be the maximum?
Probably 4.
Because the probability
of an increasing i
or more neutrons coming out
gets lower and lower as you go.
In fact, these reactions
don't even turn on until--
the n,2n reaction turns
on and around like 1 MeV.
This one turns on and
around like 5 MeV.
This one turns on
at like 12 MeV.
I was just looking up these
cross-sections before class.
So if you have a reaction
that doesn't happen
beyond your highest
neutron energy,
you probably don't
need to worry about it.
But the reason I had us write
all these extra equations--
and I think that the t-shirt
for this department needs some
updating to include
these extra terms--
is because they're
all the same term.
It is in every case,
it's an integral
over all of our stuff
of a reaction rate,
d-stuff, times a multiplier.
Every single term
in this equation
follows the exact same pattern.
So what I hope, and I would
expect out of you guys,
is that if I were to
give you this table
of possible reactions,
you would be
able to recreate this neutron
transport equation using
this template to know that
every single reaction is just
multiplier, times integral
of stuff of a reaction rate,
d-stuff, where the reaction rate
is just a cross-section times
a flux.
That's all there is to it.
Not bad when you see
that everything follows
the same pattern, right?
That's the basis behind most
of the hideous equations
that you see in all
of physics everywhere,
is if there are additive
or subtractive terms,
they'd better be
in the same units.
And so they're going
to follow some sort
of a similar template.
Not too scary when you
think of it that way.
So let's now come up
with the loss terms.
I should have planned
these boards better.
Keep these ones here
so we keep a template.
And we'll have a
minus, well, how
do we write the anything
reaction using this template?
How many neutrons
undergo a reaction
when one neutron
undergoes a reaction?
Yeah, 1.
So our multiplier is 1.
We don't have to worry about it.
We have our integral of stuff.
So we'll have to integrate over
all possible volumes, angles,
and energy.
And what's on the inside?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
total cross-section.
MICHAEL SHORT: Yep,
total cross-section
as a function of energy times
the flux, d-stuff to save time.
So don't worry, even though
the boards are laid out funny,
on the pictures of the
blackboard that we'll
put on the Stellar site, I'll
Photoshop these and arrange
them so that they're
all in sequence.
And you can see everything.
And then there's the
last term to account for.
That's the leakage term.
This one is a little different.
It's the only one that's
a little different.
And in this case, we're going
to say that our little volume
element also has
a surface to it.
And if the neutrons
leave the surface,
then they leave the volume.
So in this case, we'll have a
surface integral of our neutron
flux, say our neutron flux dS.
Because there's no reaction
happening when neutrons just
move, right.
They just go.
And so, well, we'd also have to
multiply by our normal vector.
Because every flux
is going to have
a certain number of neutrons
moving in a certain direction.
Let's say we were tracking
the flow of neutrons
through this surface right here.
And if we had a flux going
in exactly this direction,
through this surface, and
this is the normal vector,
in this case, flux,
which is a vector
dotted with the normal
vector, is just the flux.
Which is to say that if the
flux and the normal vector
are aligned in the same way,
then every neutron going
through the surface is tracked
as going through the surface.
To take the opposite example,
what about the situation where
you have a surface here and you
have a mono-directional flux
of neutrons in this direction.
And that is your surface normal.
What does the flux dotted
with the surface normal vector
equal?
0, it's just a dot product
between the direction
that your neutrons are moving
and the normal vector saying,
does it go out of
the surface at all?
So for these two limiting cases,
in this case, the fluxes just
let's say, what
is it, the number
of neutrons leaving the
surface is the flux.
In this case, no neutrons
leave the surface
because they're not actually
going through the surface.
It's a good time to mention,
again, that these units of flux
are in neutrons per centimeter
squared per second, which
is to say the number
of particles traveling
through this area in centimeter
squared every second.
I know we've gone
over it before,
but I want you to keep
these units in mind.
Because now they actually
have a little more physical
significance.
And that's why we have this
flux times normal vector dS.
That describes the
number of neutrons
that get through the surface.
The last thing we'll do, because
everything else is a volume
integral, we want this to be a
volume integral because we're
going to simplify this
in terms of getting
rid of all the volume stuff.
We're going to use what's
called the divergence theorem.
I hear some snickering.
Because I remember
this is probably
something where you were told
in 1801 or 1802, this exists.
Use it in a few problems.
Moving on.
That sound about right?
This is when you
actually use it.
So the divergence theorem
says that the integral
of some variable F dS, through
some volume element of surface,
is the same as the
volume integral of--
how does this go--
del dot F dV.
And this is going to be
quite important because one,
it gives us a volume integral.
So this is, it will be a volume
integral of our del dot flux
dV, so now everything's
in the same units.
And if we were to say forget
about our little volume
element.
Let's just assume
an infinite reactor.
Every single volume integral in
term just instantly disappears.
Because we wrote
these equations to be
identical for any dV
anywhere inside this reactor.
If the reactor is then infinite,
then all of those volume terms
disappear.
And that's the
first simplification
that we'll make
in the next class.
But right here on
these five boards,
we've developed the
neutron transport equation,
which is the absolute, most
general, highest escalated
form of how do
you track neutrons
through any volume, any
direction, any energy,
at any time.
And we'll spend Thursday
and Friday simplifying this
to something that we can solve.
The other reason that we
use this divergence theorem
is because we're going
to make an approximation.
This crazy looking
thing right here,
we will make an approximation
called the diffusion
approximation where we
assume that neutrons
are like a gas that just
diffuse away from each other.
And that's going to make solving
this really, really easy.
It's going to go from
some second order
differential or differential
integral equation
to just the equation that
you can solve with algebra.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: Do you need the dE
d-omega for the last term?
MICHAEL SHORT: Probably, yeah,
over all E, over all omega.
And that flux is going
to be of r, E omega, t.
Absolutely.
Just to make sure, everything
is in the same units,
every term has a fairly
similar template.
The only difference is leakage,
there's no reaction here.
Every single other term
constitutes a reaction.
And they all follow
this template.
So I will stop here
because it is five of.
See if anyone has
any quick questions
on what you've got here.
I'll make sure to get all
of this on the board images
so you guys can
take a look at it.
And I'll projected
up on the screen
so that we can make some
simplifications based on what
we see here on Thursday.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What is the
neutron birth spectrum?
MICHAEL SHORT: The
neutron birth spectrum
says that if you have any
old fission event, what's
the probability of
those neutrons being
born at different energies?
What this says is that they're
born between 1 and 10 MeV,
with a peak at around 2 MeV.
But if you want to track
the number of neutrons
in every energy group, you
need to know where they begin.
Good question.
So if any of the terms here are
unclear what they physically
mean, because that's what
I'm most interested in you
guys knowing, please do
ask either on Piazza,
on email, on Thursday.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What's the
difference between the big N
and the little n again?
MICHAEL SHORT: The big N
and the little n, which one?
The cursive one, or this one?
AUDIENCE: The little n
up top there and then
the non-cursive one.
MICHAEL SHORT: OK, the little
n and the non-cursive one.
The little n is the number
of neutrons in a volume,
at a certain energy, going in
a direction, at a certain time.
Big N right here is just
number density, number
of atoms per centimeter cubed.
Cursive n is the number
of neutrons at an energy,
in a volume.
We don't care where
they're going.
And the reason I write
these terms up here is we
are going to switch from
lowercase to capital,
or angularly-dependent
to angularly-independent
by making a simple
approximation to say,
we don't care what
direction they're going.
We just care if they're there.
But in real complex
neutron physics problems,
like the one solved at the
computational reactor physics
group, you need to
know all the angles.
And you need to
know the probability
or the cross-section that a
neutron coming in at this angle
leaves at that angle and
imparts a certain energy.
Because they're all different.
For the purposes of
this class, I just
want you to know
that they exist.
And the first thing we will
do is simplify them away.
But this way, you'll
be fully prepared
for 22.05 and a lifetime
of reactor physics,
if you so choose.
Who here is done a year op
in the computational reactor
physics group?
Just one, OK.
I recommend more.
They tend to be the biggest
group in the department.
They've got like
20 grad students
and probably more
year ops than that.
So try it out.
It's what makes us
us, us nukes, right,
is neutrons and tracking them
to ridiculous proportions.
OK, definitely want to let
you guys go it's one of.
So I'll see you all on Thursday.